pas
[Musique]
peut on va vous accueillir avec un thé
ou un café au niveau du deuxième kiosque
bienvenue à l'espace naturel sensible de
dioré c'est avec ce sourire que
l'association prend durée en main
accueille ce groupe de visiteurs pas
comme les autres un groupe de travail
mis en place par plusieurs directions du
département cc c'est un jeu d'acteur
parce qu'un espace naturel c'est de
multiples intérêts les intérêts de
protection des intérêts d'accueil du
public des intérêts touristiques des
intérêts de développement agricole donc
effectivement l'intérêt c'est
aujourd'hui de réunir l'ensemble de ses
acteurs pour montrer qu'on est dans un
projet commun donc projet commun qui est
bien sûr piloté et financé en partie par
le département
voilà un exemple d'intelligence
institutionnels réunir les acteurs qui
se rend compte généralement dans des
bureaux avec chacun leurs objectifs de
développement département aujourd'hui à
unifier cette visite sur les conseils de
d'une élue de l'efs de madame viviane
s'y présentent
c'est une première mais il y en aura
d'autres
[Musique]
dès les premiers pas apparaissent les
espèces endémiques au bord du chemin
ici une attention toute particulière est
faite à la nature en contrebas au milieu
des herbes envahissantes des agents en
insertion sont à la manoeuvre
l'action et physique mais chirurgicale
c'est pas un groupe isolé
c'est toute une équipe qui est derrière
derrière cette gestion en général les
gens de notre association sont
originaires de durée donc ils ont grandi
sont grands ils ont grandi à durer et
donc ils ont la volonté de prendre en
main leur quartier leur territoire la
forêt
les qui visite régulièrement
ce modèle de protection du patrimoine
naturel par des associations qui gèrent
également l'accueil du public et créer
de l'emploi à travers l'insertion existe
dans toute l'île
le département compte ainsi une
vingtaine de haine s on parle de 100
mille hectares d'espacés naturels dont
le département consacre 10 millions
d'euros pour sa préservation
enfin cette zone profitent chaque année
à huit cent mille visiteurs
ce patrimoine exceptionnel donc ce site
mais s'il est relativement stratégique à
l'échelle comme on l'évoquait tout à
l'heure du grand massif de l'est mais
aussi du nord puisque c'est une des
principales portes d'entrée
ce temps d'échangé avec les conseillers
départementaux a permis de voir
concrètement l'utilisation des
investissements publics
prenons très souvent des décisions entre
quatre murs et quand on vient sur ce
site on découvre un site qui est très
très bien entretenu le l'association
allons prendre durée en main a fait un
travail extraordinaire mais en fait tout
est important depuis la valorisation
touristique mais également l'utilisation
du site pour des projets d'envergure
autour de l'agriculture autour de
l'agroforesterie beaucoup d'acteurs
beaucoup de passionnés
on peut parler aujourd'hui de
biodiversité
on peut planter par les deux plantes
médicinales et ont peu parlé d'insertion
d'une population à l'intérieur d'un
quartier comme celui de durée je pense
que ça peut être répliquée maintenant
pour vous dire que tout est fait et que
rien et a ajouté nous puisqu'on a
toujours affaire mais cependant là on
est vraiment dans une posture écologique
ce sont des bons levier d'insertion
économique ce sont des bons leviers pour
valoriser notre patrimoine naturel ce
sont des bons leviers pour créer de
nouvelles activités notamment à travers
les plantes médicinales
cette première action de terrain et
inaugure d'autres opérations de ce genre
de quoi partager des idées de
développement du territoire
[Musique]
les enfants